oh wow look how beautiful sorry it took
me a little bit long I just had to get
dressed myself oh my God I love it ready
gorgeous I'm ready first okay and then
we'll start you know the fun part by the
way okay so what's up why would you do
that the dress is perfectly fine for you
it just felt like a little extra
cleavage that's okay okay
so we will yeah listen Layla jump in
here okay here I go gorgeous right
let me hold you shake it shake it shake
it shake the booty shake it there we go
there we go and we just made you a
Perfection perfect fitted those are hers
I feel like a goddess
my dress is so amazing Katrina designed
it right on my body to a T it's very
elegant it's classy but sexy at the same
time it's a beautiful slit I've never
worn anything still elegant or expensive
in my life it truly was a showstopper
perfect go ahead we got it so ready yes
is that it's the day you've always been
waiting for
foreign
[Music]
wow
absolutely stunning
absolutely gorgeous
[Music]
you're running out it's
it's beautiful to see her shine so
beautifully thank you
One of a Kind one of a kind or one of a
kind
girl
one of a kind sister that's right and
you're one of a kind
I never thought my wildest dreams I'd be
wearing a hook tour wedding dress by a
American Albanian designer like that's
so cool like it all
came together it all came together in
the end
[Music]